il ya une pyramide sociale où il ya un
mec qui est en haut tout seul et plus on
descend plus on est nombreux et quand on
arrive en bas on est vraiment dans la
merde
[Musique]
où
j'ai travaillé et puis j'ai fait j'étais
apprenti 14 twh pas dans des métiers
différents et j'ai jamais réussi à en
faire un seul en fait j'étais fleuriste
j'étais télégraphiste j'étais marchand
de légumes
[Musique]
très important le spectacle d'hier quand
tu as compris pourquoi les gens ont
envie d'aller voir un spectacle tu peux
en faire
[Musique]
ah non moi je veux que les gens non il
ya quand même moins d'étrangers que de
raciste en france
alors non je dire si j'ai le choix j'ai
mon train de gueuler gueuler moins
nombreux
[Musique]
comme on a voté pendant 30 ans pour des
gens compétents et intelligent je
propose aujourd'hui qu'on vote pour un
imbécile qui n'y connait rien c'est à
dire moi
[Musique]
on peut pas s'entendre avec ces gens là
parce que ils ont pas du tout le même
but que les français si je peux dire ils
veulent gagner les élections et moi
j'aurais que soit les français qui
gagnent les élections
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coluche c'est pas moi non plus je vais
jouer longtemps et personne ne s'en est
aperçu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aubin jarretière à je perds ma vie
entière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
on savait à cette catégorie de gens qui
sont des chômeurs qui ont une famille un
toit c'est pas des clochards qu'il dort
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas le pouvoir de
la faire voter mais on a on a le mérite
de la proposer puis si jamais après ça
les gens qui nous gouvernent ne voulait
pas résoudre le problème des gens qui
ont faim c'est tout con porte la
responsabilité
[Musique]
vrai qu'on remue la merde et closer
monte jusqu'au nez des mecs qui dirige
et qu'au lieu d'être tourné vers
l'extérieur du pays se tournent à peu
vers l'intérieur et qui disent qu'est-ce
qu'il ya qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qu'ils ont cela à merde on leur prend
tout leur pognon ah oui fallait leur
laisser un peu